[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRASAD SETTY: Good afternoon.
I'm delighted to welcome
Jacqueline Novogratz, CEO
and founder of Acumen,
into Google today.
And in today's
conversation we're
going to discuss a
whole bunch of topics,
but primarily one that I
think Jacqueline is really
focused on currently, which
is around model leadership.
So in the 16 years
that Acumen has
been around, they've funded
almost 100 companies,
more than $100 million.
They have positively impacted
more than 200 million people
around the world in some of
the poorest parts of the world.
And so I have been
personally involved
with Acumen myself
for several years now
and I've always been amazed
by the thinking and the vision
that Acumen has had in dealing
with some of the key issues
that we all see affecting
the world around us.
And so I've been proud to
be a part of this journey
and a proud supporter of
Acumen all of these years.
And with that welcome to Google.
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ: Thank you.
Thanks.
And thanks for all
you've done for Acumen.
PRASAD SETTY: Absolutely.
Jacqueline, I thought I'd start
off not by too much of dwelling
on the past, but
now that you have
been on this journey
for 16 years with Acumen
and certainly your own roots in
the social sector [INAUDIBLE]
well before that, tell us what
are you proudest of Acumen
having accomplished to date?
And what are some
of the learnings
from this journey that when
we talk about the future,
looking through learnings and
how they apply to the future?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ:
Great big question.
PRASAD SETTY: Yes.
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ:
Probably the biggest--
when we started Acumen,
it was clear to us
that markets alone
were not going
to solve the
problems of poverty,
nor was charity by itself.
And so we had this idea, as
you know, of patient capital.
That we would take
philanthropy and we
would invest in
intrepid entrepreneurs
for the long term, 10, 12
years to disrupt systems.
And 16 years later,
often credited
as being one of the pioneers
of the impact investing sector,
I would say what
makes us still feel
proudest is this recognition
that you can use capital
as a means to solving problems.
We get in trouble if we see
it as an end in and of itself.
But if you think about it
as a means you can actually
build individual companies
that can change systems,
whether it is taking
on the broken ambulance
industry in India and now
having a company with 3,500
ambulances and 8,000 employees,
has taken 6 million people
to hospital.
Or Delight which we
were talking about which
is two guys out of
Stanford Business
School with a solar
torch and a dream
to eradicate kerosene
10 years later
has brought light
and electricity
to 72 million people
around the world.
These companies wouldn't
have happened if we
had let business be business.
It required some very
thoughtful philanthropists
to say, take this money,
invest, give these entrepreneurs
the time to experiment,
to fail, to try again.
And lo and behold, we have seen,
as you said, 200 million people
get access to services
and new models for how
we solve problems of
poverty for the world.
PRASAD SETTY: And as you
think about then the learnings
from this journey that
influence how you're are
thinking about the future,
what stands out for you?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ:
So in many ways
we grew up against the global
backdrop of the last 15,
16 years.
If you think about it, when
Acumen was started in 2001
the world was a very
different place.
Whether you're talking
about cell phone technology,
post-9/11 versus pre-9/11
and the lack of trust around
the world, the inequality that
we're seeing as well as real
questions of capitalism
that are coming on.
So in many ways Acumen has
moved from simply focusing
on entrepreneurs that
are trying to solve
specific problems
of poverty, Prasad,
to where we fit into
building an ecosystem that
can take on the issues
of capitalism, frankly.
How do we create a more
inclusive capitalism?
Not just Acumen,
but the world is
starting to see that we
must move from shareholders
to stakeholders.
For us those stakeholders
have to include the poor
and have to include
the environment.
The world is seeing that we need
a long term, not a short term
impact, which is something
that we have stood for.
The world is seeing
that we have to start
with purpose before profit
rather than just do good and do
well.
And that we need
to define success
more than how the rich fare
but how the poor and vulnerable
are treated.
And so I think that this
drive as we've seen the world
move from interconnected
to interdependent
allows Acumen to play a very
different role on the capital
side as well as on the
kinds of entrepreneurs
and the kinds of
businesses that will
enable a more sustainable
world for all of us.
PRASAD SETTY: You mentioned
quite a few things
that I'd love for us to
explore in this conversation,
be the new way of
thinking about capitalism,
thinking about
leadership itself,
thinking more the
role of technology
and the connected society
that we have today play in.
So I'd love to explore
each of those with you.
If we start off with the broader
macro trends as you mentioned,
you do see a lot of changes
in the political nature
around the world, and the
forces of globalization
that were very prominent
over the last 20 years
as well as capitalism
being really prominent.
How do you see that
evolving, and what
role do you think Acumen and
others should be thinking about
as you think about
capitalism itself?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ:
Well, as you're speaking,
you think about how many
governments are actually
pulling inward?
Rather than this is a moment
where we need to reach outward,
which is something that
Google really represents.
The world I get to see
and Acumen gets to see
is the next generation that
is looking for new rules
altogether.
There's so much faith and trust
lost in the big institution.
What's so thrilling to me is
to see these entrepreneurs that
are using more what we
would call moral imagination
to build new systems.
So two examples,
one from Colombia,
one from the United States.
If you look at coffee
or cocoa for chocolate,
these are industries
that really were
born in slavery and colonialism
and the economics of them
have not changed all
that dramatically.
If you think about
chocolate alone,
there are 6 million cocoa
producers in the world,
90% of whom make under $2 a day.
On the back of that we're
supporting a $150 billion
chocolate industry.
Those economics
really make no sense
if you're thinking
about the farmers
that we need to depend on.
And it should be no secret or
surprise that the average cocoa
farmer's 58 years old and
most of their children
do not want to be farmers.
On the other hand,
you're starting
to see an artisinal
chocolate industry take off
where individual chocolate
bars can sell for $12, $15.
So there's a new
generation of entrepreneurs
who are completely ignoring
global commodities prices when
they are negotiating
with farmers.
They're understanding
the price that farmers--
or the cost to farmers
of actually producing.
In many cases they're
doubling those costs,
but providing a margin that is
not 30% better, but 200% better
than the global
commodities prices.
So it's left their trade
behind and substituted it
with a radical transparency
using technology
to show the farmers the whole
value chain from what they're
paid to what these
chocolate bars are sold for
to enable communities of trust.
To me that is so
incredibly hopeful
when we think about
visibility and transparency
around the products
that we want to buy,
and the new generation
cares about that stuff.
In the United States,
everybody talks
about workforce development,
certainly in Silicon Valley,
as we should.
On the other hand,
we're not doing the job
that we should be doing in terms
of getting diverse communities
into coding jobs, for instance.
We've invested in a company
called Learner's Guild just
here in San Francisco
that understands
that low income communities,
particularly of color,
often have huge stress,
families, jobs that pay
$15,000, $20,000 a year.
It's impossible to go to
a good coding boot camp
and stay in your job and
take care of your family
so that you can get the job.
So what these guys have
done is create a system
where they will give you a
10 month stipend so that you
can focus fully
on the boot camp,
at the end of which you have to
pay it back but only once you
start earning $50,000 a year.
So there's a risk sharing.
The first batch
who just graduated,
the average salary is $81,000
that these guys are getting.
And they came in at an
average salary of $23,000.
So we can do this, but it's
not traditional capital
that will enable that because
there is risk at every level.
Then Acumen can play a role.
Because what we're focused on
is solving the problem, right?
Not just making money.
What you learn is that
companies like Google
and others in Silicon Valley
have requirements for college
degrees because of h-1 visas.
So all of this stuff is
interconnected again.
Many of these communities
don't have college degrees.
So then we can intermediate
and say, wait guys,
to make this system work
we've got to change that.
And that's the
way we're starting
to think about building an
entrepreneurial ecosystem that
will enable these
companies to change
the way the world tackles
poverty, essentially.
PRASAD SETTY: Fascinating.
As you think about
the ecosystem,
one part of thinking
about these problems,
thinking about the entire
value chain, as you said,
then there was a piece
about just the people
that you're trying to find
and the leadership itself.
You've been talking a lot
about moral leadership.
Can you tell us what that
means in your own mind?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ:
Yeah, and again it's
this recognition that in
going from an interconnected
to an interdependent
world we will rise
and we will fall together.
And that we can no longer
make all of our decisions
according to a single metric.
And yet it's a lot more
nuanced and complicated
when you are making decisions
based on multiple metrics,
based on multiple stakeholders.
It necessitates
navigating the gray.
So when we think about the
qualities of a moral leader
versus just someone
who can get stuff done
and is focused
simply on efficiency,
they are individuals
that have what
we call a moral
imagination, or the ability
to have the audacity to imagine
the future and what could be,
but also the humility to
recognize the world as it is.
They are individuals who
see capital, as I said,
as something that we control
rather than let it control us.
That see investment as
a means not as an end.
Something that we don't
think about enough when
we talk about
moral leadership is
grit, resilience,
persistence, courage
to fight the status quo.
What we've learned is that if
you want to build something new
you are going to be
fighting a system that
does not want to change.
And that system is full of
bureaucracy, corruption,
and probably the worst
of all is complacency.
So do you have what it takes--
the determination,
the persistence?
So we are increasingly looking
for that in every entrepreneur
that we invest in as well as
the fellows that we're finding.
Because that will tell
us whether their ideas
are actually going to take off.
Probably just like
you at Google,
we've learned that
great ideas come and go,
but give us the leader
who have what it takes
and to do it
ethically in a world
where so many
systems are broken.
PRASAD SETTY: What's
been your experience,
Jacqueline, as you think about
developing this next generation
of leaders?
Have you been able to
find them, have you
been able to scale how
they actually learn,
and grow, and become
these kinds of role models
for the rest of the world?
Any examples, anything from
your experience you can share?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ: Yeah.
In addition to investing
in the 100 companies,
we've invested in about 400
fellows across 32 countries.
And you know, we've said it
before that talent is is fully
distributed across the world.
And daily I am blown
away by the capabilities
of these individuals who really
need access, capital, networks.
And so, yes, we're seeing
enormous change happening
at the company
level, whether it's
someone like [? Gitri ?] who
runs a company called LaborNet
in India, which a number
of Googlers have helped
and volunteered for.
But they've
essentially recognized
that education in a
traditional school room
is not going to be the answer
to the world's problems,
particularly in a country like
India where 85% of the country
has not gone past 10th grade.
And so they go into
construction sites,
work with Muslim
communities doing
beauty salons, leather tanning.
And they provide workforce
development training,
ethical training, safety
training, and then
cream those who are clear
learners to help them
get better and better jobs.
And they've already trained
half a million people.
So some of these companies
are really working at scale.
To individuals who are
just getting started,
[NON-ENGLISH] is
a Pakistani firm.
Small village in rural Punjab
couple of hours outside
of Lahore, Pakistan, who
works with local cobblers
making beautiful shoes
but never had a market.
He worked with other
fellows across Pakistan
to redesign his shoes,
rebrand his company,
now called Markhor, create
a Kickstarter campaign, used
our network to get
those ideas out
into the greater world, raised
$115,000 on Kickstarter,
now is in the Y
Combinator and is
on his way to building
a company that
provides good quality visible
jobs to village men and women
and creates an export
product for Pakistan
that the country
should be proud of.
We're seeing this kind
of innovation happening
in the highest and lowest
communities of India and Saudi
Arabia--
across the world, actually.
PRASAD SETTY: Both
these examples
show the power of connection.
How are you thinking
about technology
as an enabler of these
kinds of connections,
and what could that possibly
do for us in the future?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ: Well
one, we get so many emails
from young people who want to
start companies themselves.
And two, every time we
launch a fellows program,
we will get over 1,000
applications for 10, 20 spots.
So we started to ask
ourselves essentially this,
could we put the
courses that we're
training our entrepreneurs
and our fellows
in, could we put them online,
and would anybody take them?
And so looked at,
what are the courses
that people care most about?
Human centered design,
lean startup, storytelling,
that you can't really
be an effective leader
if you can't tell a story.
And we've now put about
30 courses up online
and we've seen half
a million sign ups.
And 300,000 people taking
these six to eight week
courses where they have to
come together in groups.
And out of these courses
what's been so thrilling
is we're seeing
companies being built
using the same metrics
of moral leadership,
whether it's Kidogo--
a Canadian and an
American who met
online, moved to Nairobi to
start a nursery, essentially,
for low income little kids,
and have now turning it
into a franchise and
are really growing.
Or I just got a note
from an Indonesian named
[? Irman ?] who took 19
courses, started a company
to work with smallholders
and really break
a lot of the barriers
that smallholders
deal with in Indonesia.
He's got about 300 employees and
is ready for a series B that--
We're starting to see this
entrepreneurial imagination
combined with
dedication translate
into real change for the world.
Can you then build a
community of individuals
who are daring to use the
skills and the attributes
they have to solve big
problems in the world?
Because that's what we need.
We need a movement right now as
we see so much that is cynical,
lacking trust, because
it lacks trustworthiness,
a huge divide between
rich and poor,
the destruction of so
much of our physical
and human environment.
We need a counter
movement that says no.
What this moment
in history offers
through our interdependence is
an opportunity like humanity
has never had in history that we
can work across lines to create
the new kinds of companies,
the new institutions that
allow us to bring our best
selves to one another.
And what the
ecosystem that we're
seeing through the fellows, the
companies that we've invested,
the online community is
showing is just that.
That this is a possibility
and it's something
that we've got to double
down on and really grow.
This movement for moral
leadership, frankly,
and a more inclusive
type of capitalism
that is measured by the
amount of human energy
we release in the world, the
amount of human flourishing
and dignity, not just how
much money we make, or even
how much money we give away.
PRASAD SETTY: Thank you.
That was very inspiring, was
very, very much in synchrony
the kinds of messages that
Google and Googlers love
to hear about.
And we try to do that in our
own environment out here.
The partnership between
Acumen and Google
goes a long way certainly, both
with financial funding as well
as office locations and so on.
And I know that a
bunch of Googlers
have also worked on
some of these projects,
including working with
LaborNet, et cetera.
What message would you
have for other Googlers who
are thinking about,
how can I work in
either the social
services sector, partner
with Acumen itself, et cetera?
Anything that you
would like to share?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ:
And you're right,
Google has been a
critical party to Acumen
from the very beginning.
2006 Google supported us
with a significant grant
to really help put
Acumen on the map.
At that time we also
were given amazing office
space in New York City
that lasted nine years.
And for that we are
eternally grateful.
So many nonprofits have to sit
away at a cubbyhole somewhere.
And having a great location
with Google right upstairs
enabled a real relationship.
And we have a huge debt
to many of the Googlers--
Craig and Kirsten [INAUDIBLE]
who've become real partners
to us, Doug Brody, others, you--
that really supported us
in concrete as well as
inspirational ways that you
probably don't even know.
And then in 2010 Google
gave us $2 million
in philanthropy to do this
early stage work in solar.
At that point we
were taking big bets
in off grid solar where very
little was actually known.
There was no investment,
particularly in Africa.
Most people relied
on kerosene, take
buying little bits
of kerosene every day
by which they would read at
night with a lot of smoke
and cook.
And trying to
convert people seemed
like it should be easy, right?
But the truth is, you have
no trust, you have no income,
you have no financing mechanism.
And you've never
really seen solar work.
And it takes a long time
to go from a push market
to a pull market.
And over 10 years we
invested about $20 million
of philanthropic capital
in these companies.
That taught us how
people make decisions,
how to market in a way
that people could hear.
It gave time for mobile
banking to enable the financing
mechanism.
We built brand recognition,
particularly Delight.
Googlers helped in
many different aspects
of that building
of a value chain
that had not existed before.
So much so that we were able
to take the Google money,
leverage it 10 times with
the $20 million invested,
and now are raising
a $100 million
for-profit initiative so that
we can prove to government
that off-grid solar is faster,
cheaper, and more effective
than extending the grid.
It takes $1,500 to get one
household connected to a grid--
and as they say,
nine years to never.
And for $170 people can
buy a 10 watt system--
three lights, a
radio, a flashlight,
a cell phone charger--
and their life changes
overnight because of what
they have done themselves.
That is where dignity
gets to start.
And we think Africa
can leapfrog the grid
just like it did with the cell
phones leapfrogging, landlines.
Googlers helped
there financially.
They helped in terms of
design, thinking about some
of the technology here.
When you go to the volunteer
work that you talked about,
many of our companies have
tech platforms for the work
that they do.
Whether it's a bank
in rural Pakistan
that has 500,000
farmers and is now
converting to mobile
banking, or LaborNet
which I was talking about
before, or Esoko, which
is a platform for
smallholder farmers based
out of Ghana and now
Kenya to give farmers
market information,
Google helped actually
take that platform and,
one, both proposed a million
dollar grant which the company
got, as well as helped design
a platform for mobile banking
and the distribution of
implements.
That's a major give
for Googlers who
went over and actually spent
time in country with companies.
So there's real
opportunity there.
There are 400 fellows that are
requiring different kinds of--
I don't even necessarily
want say mentoring,
because so much of them
are such great leaders.
But certainly technical
expertise as well as access
to networks and ideas.
There's real opportunity
there, there's
opportunities to contribute
to this kind of work
in the building
of this ecosystem.
We would love to see
co-creation of courses
I know that you
have online courses,
and some of our most
successful courses
have been co-created,
whether it's
with Fossil, the company, or IDO
on the human centered design.
And so I think that there's
a myriad number of ways
for Googlers to interact with
Acumen through the technology,
through the know-how,
through the networking,
through financial support.
PRASAD SETTY: Fantastic.
We look forward to keeping those
connections strong with Acumen
as we explore the
future together.
As I mentioned earlier
on, certainly our paths
are intertwined.
There's a lot that
we collectively
believe in both
Acumen as well as
Google in terms of being a
positive force for the world
and using technology to address
a whole bunch of problems that
have perhaps been
neglected over time,
thinking about the
use of data which
I know that's a a lot of work
that you folks are doing,
and just getting a lot more
rigorous about measurement
of impact in the social sector.
So certainly we look forward to
continuing on that partnership.
One of the other common things
that is both of interest
to you as well as
to us is this notion
of diversity and inclusion.
That is a big topic
certainly at Google,
certainly all over Silicon
Valley and the technology
industry.
And I was especially struck
by our earlier conversation
where you talked about how
you're getting groups together
of people in this attempt
to build a community, people
who would perhaps not
engage, or ever meet,
or talk to each other.
Can you share with us both
your experiences there,
as well as your
emerging thoughts
on how do you get this
global community together?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ:
Thanks, yeah.
This is something that's
keeping me up at night,
and I know it's
important to Google.
And particular when you look
at Google Translate as well
as a way that we can have
greater access to one another,
and I think that that's
actually a fifth way
that we could interact with
Googlers because our community
is so diverse.
And in fact, in one
community [? in Buxon ?]
there are 73 languages, and
many of them are getting lost.
How could Google help to
keep those not just claimed
and reclaimed, but alive?
And so what we started
to do 10 years ago
with the global fellows was
to bring together people
across lines of difference.
We realized that
at global level,
so often we end up with
people who are actually
more like each other than
sometimes they are low income
people in our own countries.
And that if we really
wanted to get to diversity
we had to have the courage
that you talked about
of cutting across all of
these different lines that
keep us separated.
Religion, class, ethnicity,
ideology, geography.
And so whether-- we've started
in three regions, Pakistan,
India, and East Africa.
And we find amazing
leaders across all sectors,
and all of these
different lines.
If you take a country like
India, which is so vast,
you have some young
Indians that have
gone to the best
schools in the world
and have graduated at
the top of their class
and want to use those
skills to make change.
Suhani Mohan, number
one at the IIT Mumbai.
Then you went to
investment banking,
and after a few
years thought, I'm
among the most educated
people on the planet,
and yet I go to the villages
and women have no access
to even basic health hygiene.
And so she started a feminine
hygiene company a few years ago
and just sold her millionth
biodegradable sanitary pad.
And is using the network
of fellows to do this.
To do that effectively,
she's actually
got to understand how people
in far flung villages who
don't speak her language, who
have a different religion, who
are in some cases deeply
conservative, how they think,
how they respond.
And so our fellows
program includes people
from those villages, but
who are incredible leaders
in their own right.
And we bring them together and
both hold up a mirror to them,
where do you get
in your own way?
What is your identity?
How do you think through it?
We use literature
as a springboard
into conversation, using moral
leaders as that springboard.
Regardless of where they
come from in the world
they will read the
same curriculum.
Everyone from Plato and Hobbes
and Rousseau to [? Huldoon, ?]
one of the great
Islamic mathematicians
and philosophers.
They read Haile Selassie,
and Chinua Achebe
of Nigeria, Gandhi, of course
Mandela, King, Aung San Suu
Kyi.
And there's a pantheon
of moral leaders
who have been engaged in the
same conversation for 2,500
years.
What is the nature of man?
How do we make trade offs
between the individual, which
we're seeing reigning
supreme in Silicon Valley,
and the community where many
of the places that we work
takes precedence?
How do you trade off
freedom and security
at this moment where so
many people are afraid?
How do you trade off
justice, or do you?
What's the difference between
justice and generosity?
What's easier?
We have those kinds
of conversations,
stepping back, reflecting, so
that you can both understand
more who you are and what your
values are and the principles
by which you live.
Because we live in
a moment in history
where our leaders are flinging
opinion at one another.
They are not standing
on principle.
They are not helping us make
sense of this tumultuous time
in the world.
And we can't wait
for them to do so.
And so by bringing these
uncomfortable groups together
and moderating these
kinds of conversations,
not only can they learn more
about themselves and each
other, but develop the tools
to have difficult conversations
across lines of difference
and then find their tribe--
their real tribes--
in the groups that
are trying to solve
the problems of education.
Regardless if they come from
a tribal village of Pakistan,
or an elite school in
India, or a slum in Nairobi,
or a university in Rwanda.
That's a tribe
because they're trying
to solve a problem together,
or off grid energy,
or health care for the poor.
That for me is so
incredibly hopeful.
And that goes to this idea
that we could create a citizen
movement that transcends.
But we can't do it if elites
are only talking to each other.
We need to bring
people who have never
been able to sit at the
table to bring those voices.
We need to stop
seeing them as needy
and recognize how
needed they are.
And that requires
this moral revolution.
We've had the
technological revolution.
I actually think
there's a yearning
for a moral revolution.
We just don't know how to do it.
And we're not seeing
it in our leaders.
But we know that we don't
like what we're seeing.
And so how do we develop
the new frameworks
within which we can
all find ourselves,
and how do we find a
minimum set of values
that we can all sign up
for and we can all share?
That actually shouldn't
be that hard to do.
We can't approach
each other with fear.
We have to have the moral
courage to start by listening.
And we can't start by
trying to convince,
we have to listen in a way
that's ready to be convinced.
PRASAD SETTY: Thank you.
Talking about courage,
one of the things
that has stood out for me is
how you, as well as Acumen,
both at an individual
level, but also
at an organizational
level, constantly keep
reinventing yourselves as well.
And think about
what is required,
what can we learn
from the past, what
is required with the
environment that we see now?
So as you think about parting
thoughts for this group
and anyone who might see us in
the big wide world of YouTube,
what messages do
you have for us?
Where are you headed personally,
as well as for Acumen?
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ: Well
you started by saying,
you know, what are the things
that you're most proud of?
And as I think back to that
beginning of our conversation,
we didn't start Acumen to prove
that with impact investing
you could make money in
low income communities.
We started Acumen because we
wanted to solve the toughest
issues of poverty.
That has become a North
Star for us, a thread.
That makes courage really easy.
Nietzsche says that
when you know your why
you can bear almost any how.
You can endure it anyhow.
And so as the world
has changed, we
have had to change to
stay true to our mission.
And that's-- on the one
hand it's courageous,
but on a much larger
hand it's thrilling.
Because I think that for
too long, and certainly
in my generation,
we divided the world
between the do-gooders
and the people
who wanted to make money.
That world doesn't
exist anymore.
One, if we are going to
create the world that we
are capable of creating,
we have to recognize
that every single
one of us is needed.
Whether you work
in a corporation,
whether you work in
government, whether you
work for a nonprofit in the
civil society or a community
organization.
And we've got to approach each
other from a place of building
trust, not thinking that I
have the answers and you don't.
I'm in the corporate
world and I'm efficient,
and you're in the
nonprofit world
and you might have a big heart,
but you can't manage yourself
out of a shoe box.
Obviously there may be
truth for individuals,
but there are not truths.
There's no capital-T
truth to that.
So one is this idea of be
audacious in the problems
that we are trying to change.
But then have the humility
to start where you are.
Just take a step.
I worry with the next
generation is there
such a focus on
perfection sometimes
that people are too
afraid to make a move?
Just make a move.
And then once you take a
step, let the work teach you.
Probably the second
big parting thought
would be that came
from my mentor
here in Silicon
Valley, John Gardner.
In this age of
celebrity we so often
focus on being interesting.
The people who make
change in the world
focus on being interested.
Find out about others.
Understand the problem
from their perspective.
Have the courage to fail,
and then just get up
and start again.
It's not the smart
people necessarily
who make the change, it's
the determined people.
And then find a
community, find a tribe
that's willing to stand
with you as you stand
with the poor and the marginal.
Because that can be
a lonely journey.
It will be a lonely
journey at times.
You got to be able to
find the joy that's
inside of it as well.
And that doesn't
happen by yourself.
That happens with the community.
And what's been so
wonderful, and joyful,
and fulfilling about partnering
with Google, and with you,
and the team that you bring
is that, like you said,
this is a journey
of kindred spirits
that are driven by answering
problems, not by being right.
And if you can take that kind
of attitude for the long term,
there's not a problem
we can't solve.
We should be bold enough
to dare to end poverty
in our lifetimes.
Not just the material
poverty, but the poverty
that's keeping us
most apart from one
another, certainly
in the United States,
and that is a spiritual sense
of impoverishment, of isolation,
of not counting,
of being left out.
And that's the one we
have to work on the most.
And there is no
way to work on it
than to pursue lives of
purpose, of meaning, of taking
on the hardest problems
that we need to solve
and can only solve together.
PRASAD SETTY: Thank you.
Thank you for living
that life of purpose,
being an inspiration
to so many people
that are in the
organization, as well as
your own fellows and enlistees.
JACQUELINE NOVOGRATZ: Thank you.
And thank you to Google.
Truly you've been with us
every step of this journey.
And I think we're at
a level and a place
right now to just go
deeper together and learn
from each other.
And I look forward to that.
All right.
Thank you, Jacqueline.
[APPLAUSE]